who knew they could sing
that's the question you'll ask yourself
after hearing these actors vocal
performances
every now and again an actor will put
their vocal abilities to the test
and prove that they can do more than
just acting some are natural singers who
are confident in their abilities
while others train for months to acquire
the right voice for a role
so let's hear which actors can carry a
tune all right we should put on some
music or something
emma stone killed it in her role as
cruella and in one scene
she could be heard singing along to
nancy sinatra's these boots were made
for walking
but she's had even more prominent
singing roles in the past
she sang in 2010's easy a and won best
actress for her role in la la land in
which she sang
all her own songs
the stranger things star will surprise
you with his singing abilities
you can hear him sing in stranger things
season 3 giving his cover of
never-ending story
when he's not playing dustin he's
singing in a band called work in
progress
he has also sung with some serious
superstars including paramore and kelly
clarkson
you may not picture loki as the singing
type but tom hiddleston has
actually played country legend hank
williams in the movie
i saw the light those are large shoes to
fill
so hiddleston took lessons from granny
winner rodney crowell to prepare for the
role
hiddleston also sang as captain hook in
the animated film the pirate fairy
maybe we'll see him carry a tune in the
upcoming loki series
i'm gonna make a change
in my life the mother of dragons has a
surprisingly good singing voice
in the movie last christmas she sang the
titular song
she can also be heard singing in italian
in a dolce and gabbana commercial
she may not sing often but when she does
she proves her talents go beyond just
acting
last christmas i gave you my heart
robert downey jr has been proving his
immense talents throughout his long
career what you may not know however
is that includes musical abilities he
can be spotted in the drama show ally
mcbeal
singing a cover of every breath you take
alongside rock legend sting
not long after this appearance downey
released his debut album the futurist in
2004.
that's impressive but let's hear how he
handles the happy birthday song
[Applause]
[Music]
jennifer lawrence hates singing she has
stated this
multiple times throughout her career
i've never once put it out there that i
think i can sing or that i even
enjoy singing this hasn't stopped
directors from forcing her to do it
however
she sang a duet in the movie joy and an
original song
the hanging tree in the hunger games
mockingjay part 1 which hit number 12
on the billboard hot 100. she might not
like doing it
but we love hearing it do you believe
let it go and into the unknown may be
the more popular songs from the frozen
franchise
but don't sleep on anna's tunes kristen
bell sang all her own songs
and she sounds absolutely amazing belle
was actually classically trained in
musical theater when she was younger
which
definitely helped her keep up with the
super talented in dina menzel
perhaps that's why she represented the
history of disney songs
alongside jimmy fallon i would sing into
the mirror just you white henry
white rhys witherspoon played june
carter cash in walk the line
and actually sang all of her own songs
she took four months of vocal lessons
and rehearsals to get ready for the
demanding role
it paid off though as she won an academy
award for her performance
she can also be heard in the 2016 movie
sing
even with this experience she stated she
is scared of singing
me singing in front of people while
they're listening to me is just
horrifying
when i was a little bitty baby my mama
woulda rocked me
in the cradle chris pine may be known
for his roles in wonder woman and star
trek but the actor has
also proved that he has quite the
singing voice he played cinderella's
prince in
into the woods showing off his disney
musical chops
he also sang in small town saturday
night where his country singing skills
were on display
kept thinking i could never live without
you by my side
the harry potter star played bell in the
2017
live-action version of beauty and the
beast which meant there were a lot of
expectations going in she was singing up
to four times a week in preparation for
the role
and we would say the hard work paid off
she provided the vocals for all of
belle's songs
and did a great job covering the iconic
tunes
just a little change zendaya lent her
voice for the greatest showman in 2017
but unlike some other actors on this
list she was already prepared going into
the role
she released an album in 2013 entitled
zendaya with one of the songs on her
album replay
reaching number 40 on the billboard hot
100 we can't wait to hear
what she does next
[Music]
zendaya's greatest showman co-star also
lent his voice to the film
and like zendaya he was more prepared
than most ephron had previously provided
vocals for high school musical 2 and 3
as troy bolton
and for hairspray as link larkin we have
to wonder
why his voice was denied for the first
high school musical
[Music]
a young anne hathaway can be heard first
singing in the 2004 movie
ella enchanted it wouldn't be until 8
years later that hathaway starred in les
miz
singing her own songs and winning an
oscar for best supporting actress
since then she has performed with barbra
streisand
singing on her 2016 album encore
find me
hugh jackman doesn't need any help when
it comes to carrying a tune
he has sung his own songs in both les
miz and the greatest showman and
performed a musical number for the
opening of the oscars
on top of all of this jackman has
actually won a tony award for his role
in the broadway musical
the boy from oz and just in case that
wasn't enough he also won a special tony
award in 2012.
so i'm roughly the size of a barge
we all remember the cup song from the
2012 movie pitch perfect
but that's just the tip of the iceberg
for kendrick's singing
she sang in all three pitch perfect
movies provided her vocals for the 2016
movie trolls
and also sang in the movie the last five
years
you don't start in three singing heavy
movies without some serious vocal chops
you gotta move slowly taking in my body
like
it's holy amy adams has always flown
under the radar as a vocal talent
even with her impressive track record
she sang in the 2007 disney musical
enchanted as well as another disney
musical movie
2011's the muppets she was also in the
public theaters production of into the
woods
she has proven herself as a talented
singer and we can't wait to hear what
she'll sing next and i learned how to
get along
speaking of into the woods emily blunt
starred in sang
in the 2014 movie she took singing
lessons before auditioning for the role
and then continued to take more vocal
lessons after getting the part
she said she was embarrassed by some of
the vocal exercises she had to do
as she was not used to such techniques
she returned to singing as the titular
mary poppins in mary poppins returns
providing some lovely tunes for the
iconic character
star shining bright above
you steinfeld starred alongside anna
kendrick in pitch perfect two and three
contributing her vocals to the movie
soundtracks she can also be heard on the
2018 bumblebee soundtrack
singing the song back to life her
talents were good enough for her to go
on tour with a-list
musicians such as katy perry and charlie
puth
when i need motivation marvel actors
have been a constant throughout this
video
and scarlett johansson adds some serious
power to that list
she was the musically gifted character
ash in the 2016 musical sing
and she nailed her songs johansen has
actually
released multiple albums worked with
david bowie
and even performed at coachella one year
you keep saying
you got something fun that's right
cosgrove played carly shea for five
seasons on icarly and sang the theme
song for the show
leave it all to me what you may not know
is that cosgrove also released an album
sparks fly in 2010. she has also
released multiple singles and eps
with the irresistibly catchy tune about
you now
hitting number 47 on the billboard hot
100.
with the icarly revival right around the
corner we wonder if she'll provide her
voice for some more
catchy tunes
[Music]
you might never guess it but pattinson
is actually a very talented musician
and singer he mostly keeps his music to
himself
but there are a couple times his music
has been heard
he sang the song willow for his movie
high life
and had two songs on the original
twilight soundtrack
he said in the past that he is too
scared to release his music
but if this is anything to go by he has
nothing to worry about
[Music]
zachary levi can be heard on the tangled
soundtrack
providing the voice for his character
flynn rider he performed two songs for
the movie
i've got a dream and i see the light he
put his talon to good use
singing one of his tangled songs to a
children's hospital patient
we can't think of a better use of music
and it's warm and real
and bright much like her twilight costar
pattinson
stewart is also shy when it comes to
singing that being said
she has actually sung before in two
movies she is credited for
multiple songs and into the wild and
even played rock legend joan jett in the
runaways
you don't land that kind of role without
the vocal ability to back it up
although her shakira impression can use
some work
[Music]
another actor who is coy about their
singing kira knightley can be heard with
some surprisingly good vocals
she sang in the 2014 movie begin again
where she played a singer-songwriter
she took singing lessons in preparation
for the movie and it sounds like it was
a good
investment she has said she never wants
to sing in public
but she did show off a rather odd
musical talent on jimmy fallon
bradley cooper was not messing around in
the 2018 movie
a star is born he played a seasoned
musician
and had to sing multiple songs he spent
about a year and a half
taking vocal lessons and also hired a
dialect coach
to get the timber of his voice just
right it wasn't an easy process
as cooper was scared of singing going
into the role
singing live was terrifying and i really
relied on her
it was definitely worth it it's
impressive to hear these already
extremely talented actors putting
themselves out there to attempt success
in another incredibly
difficult field singing for millions of
people to hear can be a very scary task
so we applaud the actors who went for it
who do you think had the best singing
voice